how do you truly listen to another human
being how do you notice them how do you
really hear them
I always hated the term active listening
if anything it's proactive
and as soon as you start to try to
anticipate where somebody's going you're
dialed in more
um because along the way
either you're congratulating yourself
for being right
or when suddenly they say something that
surprises you you really notice it like
that's not what I expected
you die then you're listening so it's
it's
proactive and then
one of the reasons
you know we name the book tactical
empathy
um name the name the book never spit the
difference but we're talking about
tactical empathy
uh calibrated emotional intelligence
what's it calibrated by first it was
experiences hostage negotiators but and
we've come to find out that our
experience is hostage negotiators
is backed up by Neuroscience another
reason why I listened to Andrew
huberman's podcast all the time heavy
heavy heavy heavy on the neuroscience
and so then emotional intelligence
calibrated by what we know about
Neuroscience what do we know about
Neuroscience I know I talk about it from
a Layman's perspective and even say whee
is an arrogant thing you know human
beings I I didn't do the research I'm
scooping up as much of it as I can as a
Layman
the brain's largely negative
I think there's ample evidence people
would argue with you as to what the
wiring is and what does what
and the limbic system and all of that
but
the brain is basically 75 negative it's
an alignment I make that contention
number one number two
the best way to deactivate negativities
by calling it out
and I could say look I don't I don't
want you to be offended by what I'm
getting ready to say
that's a denial your guard is up you're
getting ready to get mad
if I say what I'm getting ready to say
is probably going to offend you
now you relax a little bit
and you go all right what is it
and then I say it whatever it is and
you're going to be like oh that wasn't
that bad
because
we knew from hostage negotiation by
calling out the negativity deactivated
and then number of Neuroscience
experiments have been done right and
left by calling out negativity
deactivating the negativity
calling out ahead of time so like
acknowledging that this is
the that this is go ahead of time that
this is going to hurt
the experiments that I've seen
um have been when the negativity was
inflicted and then having a person that
was being inflicted upon simply identify
it just identify yeah what are you
feeling I'm angry and the anger goes
away
it's tough because I've had a few and
again we're dancing between things but
I've had a few conversations where anger
arose in the guests I spoke with
yeah and I'm not sure
identifying it
that that that's like leaning into it
and going into the depths
because
that's going to the depths of some
emotional
psychological thing they're going
through that I'm not sure I want to
explore that Iceberg with a little ship
we got I
um it's a you have to decide do you want
to avoid it
or do you want to lean into it it's a
tough choice it's the elephant in a room
it is an outfit in the room it is an
outfit especially when I think that's
the big difference between conversations
and negotiations negotiation ultimately
who is looking for closure and
resolution I think General conversations
like this
is more exploring
there's not necessarily a goal
like if you were to put like if I had to
put a goal for this conversation there's
no real goal it's curiously exploring
ideas
so that'll gives you freedom to not call
out the elephant
for for time you could be like all right
let's go to the Next Room get a snack
and come back to the elephant right
all right so I I'd make a tiny
adjustment on the negotiation definition
sure because you said I think
um
seeking closure
you use two words enclosure was one of
them goals maybe another well yeah what
is what what is negotiation well I would
say seeking collaboration
and because closure kind of puts a
little bit of a finality to it a real
problem in any negotiations always
implementation
that's why we say yeses I say we yes
there's nothing without how
and and yes and it's at its very best
it's only temporary aspiration it's
aspirational it's usually counterfeit
so if you're looking for yeah that's a
good lie yes it's usually counterfeit
it's aspirational without the how yeah
it's just a good line yeah thank you and
we're working on it I was practicing I
in front of the mirror before it came in
pretty good
you got a bright future I think
you should write a book or something
right yeah
[Laughter]
uh your book is uh excellent by the way
thanks appreciate that what am I doing
here anyway this on Earth enjoy you with
you I don't know
I'm collaborating
why me though why why'd you why'd you
want to talk to me I've heard you speak
in a few places I was like this this is
a fascinating human
um I think on clubhouse and different
places then I'll listen to some YouTube
stuff and this is
just you've meet people that are
interesting that's that's why I love
doing with this podcast is just
exploring the mind of an interesting
person
you notice people sometimes you
sometimes it's like a homeless person
that's outside of 7-Eleven I notice who
are you yeah yeah yeah it's fascinating
it doesn't like I don't look at the
resumes and the credentials and stuff
like that it's just being able to notice
a person